bonjour conseillère exécutive à la ctm à
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique chargé de l'enseignement
supérieur des affaires concernant
l'enseignement supérieur origines et là
ça se passe en ce moment même
alfred marie-jeanne d'ailleurs y assiste
le président du conseil exécutif de la
de la ctm il assiste aux obsèques de
jacques chirac en ce moment à paris est
tout à fait normal selon vous que
marie-jeanne alfred marie-jeanne il soit
bon je vais pas commenter la présence du
président alfred marie jeanne à ses
obsèques
je pense qu'il a certainement fait le
choix a dit être notamment parce que son
déplacement était prévu dans le cadre du
congrès dirigeants de france je pense
que c'est une concordance de calendrier
sinon je n'en ai pas discuté
personnellement avec lui vous savoir les
raisons de sa présence et son choix mais
un président d'une institution régionale
qui assistent aux obsèques d'un ancien
président de la république français
voilà un étudiant un alfred marie jeanne
qui est par ailleurs on le rappelle
président du mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais
c'est vrai ça peut surprendre de ce
point de vue sinon je pense qu'ils
seront ou qu'ils sont plutôt nombreux 1
les présidents de régions ou de
départements français à être présent
pour les obsèques d'un ancien président
de la république
retour sur la séance plénière de
l'assemblée de martinique que la semaine
dernière dans un climat manifestement
apparemment selon moi un peu moins un
peu moins tendue
comme si les débats se font un peu plus
feutrée notamment avec l'opposition mais
il y a toujours aurélie n'est là
toujours en arrière-plan ces
récriminations
quant à une éventuelle forme
d'omnipotence du conseil exécutif par
rapport à l'assemblée
oui je pense que cette plénière n'a
cette plénière de rentrée a été on dira
plutôt calme parce qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment non plus de sujets
problématiques ou polémique
même s'il ya eu quelques interventions
qui ont pu créer quelques troubles
d'ailleurs la plénière devra se
poursuivre demain puisque elle n'a pas
pu aller elle n'a pas pu aller jusqu'à
son terme faute de quorum
faute de quorum c'est vrai ce qu'on peut
regretter effectivement dans les
rapports entre exécutif et assemblées
c'est parfois ce manque d'huile dans les
rouages cette place qui n'est peut-être
pas laisser à l'assemblée qui doit avoir
un pouvoir d'initiative d'ailleurs les
textes ne vont pas à l'encontre de ce
pouvoir d'initiative
en tout cas pour ma part mes projets
sont passés sans problème les rapports
que j'ai eu à présenter et je dois dire
que depuis la mandature g2 parfaite
relation avec les élus de l'assemblée de
tout bon et notamment les élus des
commissions avec lesquels je travaille
et que j'associe en amont au projet un
majeur que je souhaite pas ôter ces
atteintes ou les conseillers exécutifs
ont la même méthode fond comme vous
est-ce qu'il y en a pas certains qui
travaillent un peu trop seul ou qu'avait
que l'exécutif ait pas suffisamment
liens que l'assemblée chacun sa méthode
en tout cas pour ma part je considère
que je n'ai pas la science infuse et que
pour que les dossiers et puisse aboutir
il faut que chacun se sente impliqué que
chacun y apporte aussi sa touche donc
dès lors que moi je suis arrivé à la
collectivité territoriale notamment pour
le projet de règlement des deux
étudiants gelé travailler avec les
services bien entendu mais aussi avec
les élus de la commission pour qu'il
soit adopté ensuite à l'unanimité cette
année nous avons effectué le même
travail
j'ai même souhaité associer des
partenaires du secteur notamment la dom
le crous le claj pour le logement
étudiant sollicité aussi le conseil
départemental de la jeunesse et d'autres
associations d'étudiants maintenant ce
projet n'a pas été validé
et par l'exécutif je le regrette mais en
tout cas la démarche se voulait
partenariale et c'est dans ce sens que
je souhaite travailler alors on va venir
à la rentrée universitaire aux affaires
des études supérieures et notamment
l'aspect dé des aides aux étudiants
effectivement mais le début de cette
séance plénière la semaine dernière a
été marquée aussi par la présence et
l'intervention orale des représentants
enfin deux représentants de syndicats de
la police des douanes et du centre
pénitentiaire alors qu'ils vous ont un
petit peu alerté cissé besoin en était
mais surtout qui vous ont exposé leur
situation
la situation de la martinique par
rapport à un fort sentiment d'insécurité
un compte tenu de ce qui s'est passé
aussi
ces derniers temps et puis donc voilà
des forces de l'ordre qui ont des
doléances quant à plus de moyens pour
distille renforcer la protection
notamment de notre jeunesse
oui c'est un sujet très important pour
le territoire
il ya un sentiment un véritable
d'insécurité près d'une vingtaine
d'homicides cette année les chiffres
sont alarmants
une cinquantaine de tentatives ex
domicile tout à fait justement tout à
fait et je crois que là l'occasion de
cette plénière où ils ont été invités
par le président claude lise a fait état
de cette situation il y a eu une unité
syndicale étendue d'ailleurs aux forces
de douane et de la prison je crois que à
cette unité syndicale doit s'ajouter une
véritable unité politique pour obtenir
davantage de moyens humains et matériels
pour sauvegarder la sécurité de tous les
martiniquais
c'est un enjeu très important et
d'ailleurs à ce titre le député hani
leur a proposé une commission d enquête
parlementaire sur le trafic d'armes
il a associé l'ensemble des députés
martiniquais et guadeloupéens et
sollicité le soutien de l'ensemble des
mères c'est vraiment là encore la
nécessité de travailler ensemble pour
résoudre ces problèmes qui concernent
tous les martiniquais bien sûr en allant
aussi au fond parce qu'il y à des
questions une question comme la sécurité
se règle aussi à travers l'éducation la
formation la prévention de la
délinquance et l'insertion
professionnelle
nous venons donc à la rentrée
universitaire aurélie n'est là puisque
vous on le rappelle vous êtes la
conseillère exécutive chargée des
affaires concernant des études
supérieures alors entre universitaires
dans un contexte toujours quand même
tendu entre paul de guadeloupe paul de
martinique en fait surtout présidence de
l'université des antilles en guadeloupe
et le pôle de martinique
mais d'abord les aides aux étudiants
alors il ya un changement il ya un
changement de méthode à la ctn
concernant le circuit un de ses dossiers
des nos étudiants un changement de
méthode avec une incidence sur le
calendrier de versement qui a pris du
retard là d'ailleurs là au moment où on
parle alors alfred marie jeanne a pris
la main sur cette affaire alors j'ai
envie de dire ce n'est peut-être pas
nouveau depuis l'année dernière et
effectivement le président tient à
assister aux commissions des deux
étudiants une incidence sur le
calendrier parce qu'effectivement il
faut nécessairement faire en fonction de
son emploi du temps mais en tout cas
tout est mis en oeuvre au niveau des
services avec qui je suis en
collaboration pour que les dossiers
soient étudiées le plus rapidement
possible et que ces aides parviennent
aux familles dans les délais les plus
courts possibles pour ça d'ailleurs pour
cette rentrée
ça y est les aides sont versées c'est
arrivé c'est c'est dans les tuyaux
attention plusieurs n'ont pas encore
puisque nous n'avons pas encore eu notre
première commission des aides aux
étudiants
donc j'espère dont parle essentiellement
de bourse
on parle de beauce alors il faut
rappeler quand même que c'est un
dispositif qui est complémentaire à la
bourse versée par le crous c'est un
dispositif volontariste de la
collectivité territoriale
d'ailleurs les étudiants ont jusqu'au 31
octobre pour déposer pour déposer leur
dossier
il y a des problèmes des difficultés
aussi sur le campus
concernant la licence professionnelle en
biotechnologie et bio industrie alors
faut refaire un petit peu la jeunesse de
de la faire c'est une licence qui a été
donc supprimée en fête ou annulé je ne
sais pas s'ils ont pu dire oui alors
c'est une licence qui existaient qui a
qui devrait qui devait pardon ouvrir
cette année et qui finalement une année
de test il ya une année où il fallait
faire le bilan de cette de cette licence
qui est soutenu par la collectivité
territoriale
et puis au mois de juillet nous avons
appris qu'elle n'allait pas ouvrir parce
que l'iut qui devait la porter à
considérer qu'il n'y avait un problème
de soutenabilité financière
alors si à ce point moi j'ai été alerté
par des enseignants du département
scientifique par des étudiants qui
avaient déjà fait leurs démarches
d'inscription pour cette naissance parce
que voilà il ya des étudiants qui voient
leur leur cursus
enfin perturber un pour le très cool
tout à fait on a près d'une quinzaine
d'étudiants qui sont concernés qui
avaient poussé atteint même déjà trouvé
une entreprise pour réaliser leur
alternance
face à cette situation je me suis dit
qu'il fallait chercher toutes les
solutions possibles pour permettre
l'ouverture de cette licence en tout cas
son financement et nous avons organisé
une réunion avec les services notamment
de la direction des fonds européens
il s'avère que cette licence pourrait
être financé par des fonds européens par
du fser à près de 70%
donc le tri en cours du dollar et de
marie exactement ces associations de
l'université à ce tire lui d'ailleurs
tout à fait donc nous avons
collectivités territoriales de
martinique indiqué très clairement au
président de l'université que les
financements étaient possibles ce que je
veux dire à travers cela c'est qu'avant
de se résigner il faut explorer toutes
les pistes possibles chercher des
solutions et on les trouve
lorsqu elles lorsqu'elles existent en
tout cas j'espère que cette licence pour
l'avenir de ces jeunes ouvrira bel et
bien cette année chacun prendra ses
responsabilités
en tout cas pour ma part je pense avoir
fait mon travail à ce niveau
origine et l'on va on va conclure alors
il dit en perspective les élections
municipales
les préparatifs se font déjà comme il
faut ici ou là y compris à pays à votre
parti désormais un donc vous préparer
ces municipales vous y allez vous a dû
concilier votre décision est prise et
vous avez laval 2 du parti de pays a
alors je suis bien entendu soutenu un
par pays a donc je suis vice présidente
avec les remontées du terrain je dois
dire que toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour que je sois belle et bien
présente pour ces élections municipales
entouré d'une équipe motivée et
dynamiser aussi par ses retours du
terrain parce qu'il ya un véritable
enthousiasme
le maire ne se représentant pas je crois
qu'il ya une envie de souffle nouveau
pour la commune pour que ducos rayonne à
hauteur de son potentiel à hauteur de
ses atouts et je dois dire que j'ai
toujours été sur le terrain je ne les
jamais quitté auprès de la population
auprès des associations
d'ailleurs j'ai intégré le comité
directeur du new star kim en a fait la
proposition
et puis je suis depuis plusieurs années
maintenant au comité directeur aussi de
l'association des seniors les résident à
de ducos c'est vraiment faire vivre la
commune être aux côtés des gens h 10
toujours la politique c'est d'abord
aimer les gens ça peut paraître bateau
mais c'est vraiment ça sur les propos
d'une candidate c'est très probablement
ça y est là on l'a bien compris il faut
conclure alors il va donner rendez-vous
aussi à la population à la réunion de
rentrée de pays à qui aura lieu
justement à ducos le vendredi 11 octobre
à 19h donc le rendez vous est donné pour
cette pour cette belle rencontre et du
co sera belle évidemment présente ce fut
quand le vendredi
le vendredi 11 octobre en octobre voilà
voilà comme par hasard à ducos à
l'emploi au manoir de primes avait
combien
merci aurélie n'est là d'avoir participé
à ce 5 à 10 bonne journée à toutes et à
tous merci
donc